since the dawn of the internet there
have been certain pop culture debates
that have sown discord
across the globe coke versus pepsi
android versus iphone dc vs marvel
topics that have sparked years of brain
numbing argumentation online but these
petty feuds pale in comparison to the
holy wars waged by a certain group of
web dwellers
with the glass ceiling broken all the
oppressed groups shall prosper
especially the most oppressed group of
all gabers
console wars peripheral debates or a
spicy take on your digital fashion sense
gamers are very particular and very
defensive about the things they love
what is the reasoning
what is the reasoning behind the the
notorious heimerdinger nerf
heiberger is
over
performing
in top
mid and bot lane
at high levels of play
give me your ding dong go yourself
you stupid mother
but when it comes to the current esports
zeitgeist
there is perhaps no debate more
contentious than the one between cs go
and valorent on the one side you have cs
fans who are passionate experienced
aging and think valorante is child game
then there are the valorant stands who
are fresh-faced enthusiastic and see
their tack shooter cousins as a bunch of
butthurt boomers but with the lines and
the sand firmly drawn almost all notable
competitors and content creators have
made their allegiances clear in cs you
gotta learn every single flash and smoke
and nade and molly lineup to be an
effective player
in this game
you're relying on your team to be the
effective players in those roles and
you're focused more on your role and i
love that
you gave up on unexpectedness i
understand valor
this game is horrible dude no wonder if
died it's going to be like the
the new age counter strike right that
people really like that the kids are
going to want to play
but uh for old guys like me
i think you counter strike
but there are some who manage to
walk the fence neutrals whose historical
love for counter-strike can never be
fully broken even in the face of
something colorful and new as tempting
as it may be but i have never forgotten
about the cs community man it's just
it's where i came from people always ask
me so valen's way better that's why you
play it more i'm like dude it's more fun
to play something
different when i'm not you know
competing but there is one colossal
content creator who has chosen to
navigate this minefield
a little
differently a polarizing heel of a head
clicker who despite having written his
name into the history books of valve's
fabled franchise has seemingly become
the poster boy for its rival ip i am of
course talking about none other than
tariq tariq chalik
yeah smoke i heard him
throw came through
hello hello
i'm in my own head i'm doggy i'm playing
like a dog
oh my goodness
let me gracious
dude that was stuck on his head bro
since stepping away from competitive cs
go in the spring of 2021 tariq has gone
from being one of nacs's greatest
champions to shockingly what appears to
be one of its biggest haters yes like
it's the easiest way to
for me to lose my erections
so what inspired tariq to walk away from
the game that defined him for years only
to fall into the loving arms of one that
he initially didn't raid at all how has
he been able to become one of twitch's
biggest streamers by inciting a civil
war within his own fan base and more
importantly
should a single word that he says about
either game
actually be taken at face value
you might get a global you might get a
silver or even worse you might get a
valerian player
all right guys instead of the usual sub
and subscribe spiel i give you i'm gonna
ask instead that you check out our
newest show worth where last week we did
an episode on jks's incredible stand-in
performance at katowice earlier this
year
be sure to check it out okay so it goes
without saying but i'm gonna say it
anyway tariq is certified counter-strike
royalty he has consistently been one of
the game's most popular streamers and
more importantly his professional career
was nothing short of exceptional most
notably at the boston major alongside
his compatriots on cloud nine tarik won
north america's first and only major
championship and he wasn't just along
for the ride he was named the
tournament's mvp for his outstanding
individual performance tarik now trying
for the no scope schedule is there oh my
god derek's still staying alive inside
the box not always easy to play on the
ct side no i mean very good if you get
into the tough economic situation you're
just almost done with great double kill
from taric don't lose the weapon he gets
a third a fourth in the round holding
the angle once again but does he go high
does he go low it is a dance and now
they concede multiple angles turret
going takes all of my slip down guarding
on 11 hp reigns peaks and he gets the
angle now superior angle is there a
diffuse for the ct side the 9 just yet
they're spamming the grenades they're
touching the bomb and now goes rain
another bob is trying to defuse it again
but no guardian gets taken down
absolutely unreal ranked cloud9 and the
score is tight
but as we all know in the topsy-turvy
world of counter-strike it's hard to
stay on top for long and after a few
years of roster jumping inconsistent
results and covid putting a massive
dampener on cs go and na during the
online era tarik decided to put his
illustrious competitive career on pause
in april of 2021 to instead focus his
attention on content creation so over
the next few months tarik started
streaming and uploading to youtube more
consistently and when i say consistently
i mean
every god damn day whether he was
pugging with washed up boomers or
smurfing with his former teammates tark
quickly became the choice spot for
anyone looking for some truly unhinged
cs go content baby i'm saying i'm not
the only one who has this problem it's
just see us in general no i i i see
other streamers my words
what are you talking about
[Music]
too
i'll eventually one heaven
what's that what's happening bro
you guys don't see where you died i
asked three times not a single calm
walk out and i'll start with
[Music]
dude report this kid for throwing report
him dude it's a liquid fan this kid's
such a nerd he's thrown on purpose dude
now it just so happens that right around
the time that tariq made this big career
move
valerant had been released and was
taking the streaming world by storm
everybody who was anybody was playing
riot's shiny brand new tax shooter and
while tariq held out longer than most he
eventually decided to see what all the
hype was about but it's safe to say that
at first
he wasn't exactly
convinced
you see like many other seasoned counter
strikers
tarik had his
reservations about valrant the gunplay
wasn't as consistent the utility felt
restrictive and the movement was
molasses compared to cs go but as much
as valoran's differences initially irked
tariq it started making more and more
appearances on his stream not just
because it was wildly popular but
because it offered tariq two things he
notoriously loved one a reason to grind
two
an outlet for sweaty competitions
bro i just dismantled them now as
expected as soon as taric started to
become really comfortable with valorent
people started harassing him suggesting
ad nauseam that he like every other
north american cs go competitor
go pro and while he obviously had the
technical ability it was hard to deny
how lucrative and rewarding his
dedication to streaming had become but
even beyond playing the game tark's
stream had become something of a hot
spot for competitive valorant whether
you were a new esports fan interested in
watching for the first time or an
elitist cs go lover curious to learn the
game from someone you respected tarik's
vct watch parties were the place to be
[Music]
because i believe in the rotation
just got two kills in mid by the way
this kill well yes might be impactful
you
kill that now
now when most streamers move away from
the game they originally made their name
in their viewership tends to take a hit
but that never seemed to be an issue for
tariq and that might be a result of his
hidden talent no not his knack for
ceremoniously clapping cheeks but rather
his natural ability to
let's say
disturb the peace you see long before he
was known as the content king to valor
and kitties tarek was known by cs stans
as the content criminal a title bestowed
upon him by the great inimitable
superstition referencing the fact that
tariq is and always has been happy to
make content around being a bit of a
disturber
i'm being spammed holy i like that
bug then bugged in one hp bugged him
plugged in
any bugs any bugs any dance any bug
dance
bike bug
what's going on bug then love steal's
law still's law
dutch nissan
bro do something please
[Music]
here we go
eric's literally
popping on duracell battery i'm
literally in some room look at this
i'm literally in song's room
i'm inside song's room
of course over the years
winding up his peers has proven itself
to be light work for someone with
tarik's gift so in order to truly test
his ability to stir the pot
tarik decided to play up the natural
already existing cs valorante divide in
his fan base
by
pitting both sides against each other
you see when it comes to making fps
content in north america valorant is
undeniably the king like just look at
tarik's youtube channel and you can see
that it's just true but to appease his
die-hard cs audience tarik knew that
throwing slight jabs at riot's game
could quell any concerns that he was
well
a filthy sellout because at the end of
the day all that cs fans ever want to
hear is that counter-strike is in fact
the king of shooters
so
he drip-fed them
exactly that cs is so much harder man
not only is the game harder but being a
pro is so much harder it's time to try
that sure was farming these
and valerian dude now he
comes over to see us and like he's
having a hard time
at that point i'm considering to go back
if i were him you're like this
well then we're shooting back
this stupid cartoon
cartoon network looking ass characters
games dog i tell you dog now
to be fair
this is toric we are talking about so in
reality csgo fans weren't safe either i
don't play as much as i used to it's
just because like valerian's like new
and exciting and
it gets me like turned on and when
i play
yes like
it's the easiest way to
for me to lose my erections
i think cs fans are very die hard
bandwagon like
they've been watching cs for like
countless years
and it just seems like a group of old
men that are angry old men to me
honestly
ballerina is so much harder than csgo
there's so many abilities
just so much like how many specifics
that i can't really explain to you guys
yes that is right tarek the supreme
disturber that he is turned the cs go
versus valorent debate into a war of
attrition in which he was essentially
the arms dealer but funnily enough
amidst all the mayhem and the memes
what tariq instigated wasn't really an
immature if not ill-willed battle but
rather
a conversation a forum where both sides
of his community could put him on blast
and poke fun at each other without
taking themselves or their games too
seriously and even though tariq was
certainly enjoying himself whipping up
storms and watching them from a
distance every now and then he offered
his viewers sincere insights into the
states of both games because whether
die-hard cs fans want to admit it or not
tariq wasn't just playing valorent more
because of its wild popularity
he was playing it more
because he actually liked it lately i
haven't been feeling cs that much it's
been kind of boring a little bit i don't
know because it's only fun when we 5q
the problem with cs is there's nothing
to like there's nothing to there's
nothing to do like i'm going to go on cs
and i'm just going to pug
and the only fun in it is plugging on my
friends only 5q otherwise like there's
nothing to grind for strive for
do anything like i'm just going to pug
and it's fun because we control around
and it could be fun like in pugs and
but
valerian it's new it's different for me
there's the leaderboard i can strive for
something i'm learning new things at the
end of the day tarek isn't some
two-faced sellout who's profiting off of
teasing people he's a genuine
down-to-earth dude whose love for fps
has allowed him to grow massively by
uniting two disparate audiences and he's
achieved it by simply being himself
that's insane
what are you saying it's not that good
bro look at the detail in this drawing
man look at my calves look at the
overheat text
look at this freak in front of me look
at my abs
and if anything what he's done with his
mischievous antics
is shine a light on just how absurd it
is that there would ever be any sort of
tension between these two communities
there's no real betrayal in liking both
games and for a guy like tariq who has
given so much of himself to
counter-strike i think it's safe to say
that he has earned the right to stream
whatever the hell he wants without
having to justify it
to anybody yes is like uh
how can i put this my ex-wife
my ex-wife it's like my ex-wife dude i
love seeing her every now and then but
like
i'm i'm married to a new girl now like
we can have we can have dinner every now
and then
like we could you know we can do this we
can do that but
i'm i found someone new
i am of course talking about none other
than tariq
tariq jelik
i'm pretty sure that's how you say his
name but i have very very little
experience in
turkish
pronunciations
that was not enough
[Music]